[Music]
okay
so patrick dempsey is back on grey's
anatomy and isaiah washington is feuding
with catherine heigl
seriously what year is it again i'm
sorry
on monday more than a decade after his
controversial exit from the hit
abc drama isaiah took to twitter to slam
his former co-star catherine
accusing her of saying that he should
never be allowed to speak
publicly quote this woman once
proclaimed that i should never be
allowed to speak
publicly again the world agreed with her
proclamation back then
and protested for my job and my head in
65 languages
i wish i was on twitter in 2007 because
i will
never stop exercising my free speech and
just in case you weren't clear who he
was talking about
he included a picture of catherine along
with his tweet
yikes this all started back in 2006
catherine who played dr izzy stevens on
the show alleged that
isaiah who played dr preston burke had
made a homophobic slur towards their
co-star tr knight on set
the now 57-year-old actor denied the
claim at the 2007
golden globe awards no i did not call
trf
it never happened and that's when
catherine reportedly declared that
isaiah needs to just
not speak in public abc later announced
isaiah would not be returning to the
show for its fourth season
and a few months later during an
interview with larry king live
he admitted that he actually did use the
derogatory word while arguing with
patrick dempsey
about being late to work i said several
bad words as well as he did to him
to him about how i was feeling i said
there's no way you're going to
treat me like the b word or p word
or the f word you can't treat me this
way in front of our crew
so you weren't referring to being an f
person or
never anybody else never larry still
isaiah penned an official apology
and before being let go from gray's he
shot this psa
for glad when you use words that demean
a person because of their sexual
orientation race or gender
you send a message of hate a very
powerful message
but we all have the power to demand
better from one another and ourselves
and two years later in 2009 he echoed
that sentiment when it caught up with
him on the set of his photo shoot for
the no
hate campaign in support of gay marriage
everyone should be able to
have their dignity and their pride and
their integrity
and their honor so that's one of one of
the reasons why i'm here but apparently
that whole
catherine thing isn't water under the
proverbial bridge for isaiah
in addition to that tweet that i
mentioned earlier he also wrote that
catherine was quote
the first karen and when another fan
asked why he was digging up the past
he tweeted quote because it's the truth
the end et has reached out to reps for
tr night
isaiah and katherine for comment do you
think that there's any chance in the
future that you will regret leaving
grey's at all
um yeah i do every day you know it's
it's a it was a really hard choice to
make and
you never quite know was it the right
choice or the wrong choice catherine
left the hit show a few years
after isaiah in 2010 and now a source
close to the actress tells et quote
catherine stood up for her close friend
twice when isaiah publicly outed him and
called him
that's hate talk not free speech she is
proud that she stood up for him
catherine is and always will be an
advocate and ally to lgbtq community